bonjour
je voudrais vous inviter nous inviter à
embarquer dans un voyage ensemble un
voyage en l'avenir
un voyage en harmonie pour passer de
l'ultra capitalisme un plus sage cap
d'humanisme du capitalisme au cap
l'humanisme parce que si l'être humain
est capable du pire
pour survivre il est aussi peut-être
capable du meilleur
pour vivre ensemble dans l'avenir alors
cap ou pas cap
mettons le cap vers l'éden l'éden
daurade au letten dorado ensemble sur le
même radeau tous des héros peut-être
même libre sans égaux avec le champ des
possibles en écho
si vous êtes d'accord quand je dis cap
je veux voir tout le monde dira
l'humanisme cap cap cap
ça résonne comme une évidence dans le
long terme isme
alors est ce nous faisons une pause une
pause pour composer la métamorphose du
cosmos en osmose
c'est vrai l'humanité si belle comment
lui être infidèle dans nos décibels je
ressens déjà l'odeur du parfum des rêves
dans le bonheur d'un jardin d'éden
[Musique]
mes chers citoyens du monde universel
cher à mme révolutionnaire chaire
talents complémentaires
nous sommes tous extra ordinaire donc au
lieu de regarder chacun de son côté la
forêt qui tombe cultivons ensemble
l'arbre des possibles d'un nouveau monde
la terre notre oasis où chacun peut
apporter de l'eau de vie à l'édifice et
où l'avènement d'un paradis réside dans
ce changement de paradigme un petit
sacrifice pour l'homme un grand bénéfice
pour l'humanité est une société du bien
vivre ensemble en harmonie à notre
portée
donc s'il vous plaît arrêtons de vouloir
être numéro 1
et soyons justes sans faire de numéros
en étant non pas politiquement correct
mais humainement correct un parchemin de
demain pour notre communauté de destin
commun envie de changer de statut quo
car si l'histoire se répète
peut-être pas la planète parce que
qu'allons nous faire
si un jour la perse mettant en grève au
final on récolte ce que l'on sème dans
la sève de nos rêves alors écoutons
cette voix qui s'élèvent dans le ciel
l'humanité superbe quand elle se
réveille avec l'horizon d'un paradis sur
terre dame nature recherche
amoureusement homme mature
mais les certitudes demeure la merde
toutes nos certitudes et s'il n'y a
aucune vérité
il ya par 37 milliards de réalité la
seule question qui nous est posée
comment les réconcilier à l'intérieur
d'un projet de société pour l'humanité
l'harmonie en rêve universel univers
elle à ses côtés afin de terminer
ensemble sur la ligne d'arrivée et
redorer lettres de noblesse de notre
biodiversité
tel un film de cape et de paix de calme
et de bonté sur le lac de la fraternité
donc bienvenue à tous dans un voyage
poétique dans le futur tel un hommage
authentique à nos cultures
un passage romantique pour constructeur
l'art de vivre ensemble dans l'harmonie
de la nature des rêves de solutions à
l'utopie de la révolution intérieure à
l'harmonie l'harmonie l'harmonia
l'intérieur de soi avec autrui avec la
nature les religions les galaxy où ce
qui importe n'est pas ce qu'on réussit
mais ce qui nous réunit ce mot si
essentielle qui signifie l'accord
l'union le compromis le nirvana le point
génial
les cayes la voix duding étudiants
contre la loi de king kong
l' équilibre du monde l'aimant autour de
la planète qui nous relie sur la colombe
c'est la musique de la ville en fin de
compte la clé de fa mi terrestre est la
clé de sol la svls
[Musique]
alors épouse ont la condition humaine et
embrassons notre planète vers un
printemps des peuples est une grande
révolte de l'aisne
on est tous des citoyens universelle en
quête de sens avec un droit de visite de
par naissance
en attendant notre humaine et sens
c'est-à-dire des êtres de conscience
dans l'église de renaissance car non le
peuple ne veut plus de sens ni de l'âme
élevés du sens et de l'âme il ne veux
plus de guerre sans merci
il veut une paix avec des mercis
nous sommes 7 milliards de colibri qui
essayons de cessez-le-feu en formulant
ce même voeu d'un cercle planétaire
vertueux ne t'attaques pas au système
des modes le et l'avenir sera majestueux
telle est la voie du milieu pour être
tous demain des milliardaires en heureux
et si l'émerveillement et le début de la
sagesse faisons l'éloge de la
gentillesse pour faire éclore de
nouveaux indicateurs de richesse
on ne veut pas un retour sur
investissement on veut un retour sur
l'humain dans une économie virtuelle pas
pour le commun des mortels mais pour le
bien commun des vivants sur la terre en
mesurant non pas le taux de croissance
mais l'auto de conscience de nos valeurs
et où lee a n'est pas l'intelligence
artificielle mais l'intelligence de
l'âme humaine et où la somme de nos
bonnes actions est supérieure à celle de
toutes les transactions
car le progrès n'est peut-être pas d'en
avoir mais simplement d'être et de
l'incarner dans le miroir de nos traits
d'union
[Musique]
alors oui mes chers amis
habib sy à pipi des ponts ça qu'ils font
les bons amis dans le monde de
l'harmonie où ce rêve éveillé d'une
nouvelle république
le république de l'harmonie avec un
triptyque politique poétique et
politique dans la cour des comptes des
enfants fantastiques
car dans l'humanité il y a une idée dans
république il ya denrées public et
aidants poétique il ya éthique et sans
haine
il y as litres chaque être humain unique
dans la mosaïque d'un ensemble magique
nous sommes tous des artisans de
l'avenir avec nos âmes de construction
massive des maîtres de cérémonie de
chacune de nos vies à la recherche de
compromis donc développons la conscience
de l'art de vivre ensemble avec la
société civile sans aucun parti pris
si ce n'est le lâcher prise de la
bastille
l'intelligence collective serait ce de
nouveau messi est ainsi l'utopie un
possible avenir plus impossibles à venir
donc voici un appel à long terme de
projets et à court terme de progrès afin
de voir le nous dans un jeu de société
dans le calendrier de la prée pourquoi
ne pas constituer à côté du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies un conseil de
l'humanité deux nations unies vers
l'avenir
rempli de sai chaque fois les croyances
peuples et cultures seraient représentés
de thé puis charles de politique pour
l'harmonie la paix l'amour la beauté la
dignité responsable de fixer un chemin
pour notre destin commun la fraternité
écologique et le vivre ensemble les
droits de l'humain et l'éveil des
consciences l'éducation pour tous et la
protection de l'enfance un projet commun
pour que demain se rassemblent un
libéralisme solidaire avec une
croissance qui a du sens d'une
réconciliation religieuse qui conserve
les essences un optimisme d'espoir et de
bienveillance pour notre interdépendance
même si on ne parle pas de cela même
langue on avancera un jour quand même
ensemble dans le même sens avec un mot
clé la reliance de nos 7 milliards de
nuances donc oui on en appelle aux loups
solitaires de rejoindre un tous
solidaires pour qu'on délibère ensemble
de l' essentiel pour l'avenir de
l'univers une belle photo de famille
humaine avec le sourire sur les rêves
tous les chemins de l'amour mais à
l'homme et la femme finale puisque
l'intérêt général devenir notre
principal quête du graal
le futur c'est le présent plus epsilon
dans la co écriture d'un nouveau tome
avec des citoyens des quatre clubs
fera le monde en disant à tous namasté
salue nos salam sall rouge
donc poétise on est harmonisons pour les
nizon et humanise on irait en vente ont
erré en chanteuse pour que cette
génération rentrer dans le futur comme
la génération de l'harmonie celle qu'a
dit oui à la vie
oui à l'avenir oui à l'utopie et que
soit inscrit au panthéon de l'humanité
aux humains l'harmonie reconnaissante à
l'unanimité et pour qu'enfin ce début de
siècle soit signal jamais n'ont pas fait
pour vendetta 1 25 novembre mais faits
pour vivre ensemble avec l'avenir avec
un grand a et on se retrouvera alors
dans dix ans sur la place de l'harmonie
aux abords de la venue de la grande et
met au coeur de notre humanité
donc gardons l'espoir de ne faire qu'un
sur le parchemin de notre destin commun
la terre notre jardin l'amour notre
parfum et le partage notre chemin vers
de meilleurs lendemains
donc oui il était d' il est temps
d'écrire demain pour conclure ces
quelques vers sachez qu'un homme sans
rêves et comme un oiseau sans elle est
un peuple d s'élève est capable de bien
des merveilles
un pour tous et tous en choeur à la
recherche du bonheur qu'on peut pour
composer notre chef-d'oeuvre avec
l'humanité à coeur ouvert carpediem
mettons le cap sur l'éden ps on ne naît
pas humain on le devient l'être humain
et comme un orphelin depuis des
millénaires dans une odyssée humaine
comme le parcours d'un lion pour ceux
qui ont vu le film
reparti vers là d'où il vient pour
retrouver le château de sa terre mère à
la gloire de son père qui repose dans le
ciel parce qu'on n'est peut-être pas
tous nés sous la même étoile et on est
tous nés sous le même soleil
donc je voudrais vous inviter à tous
levés nos rêves de vivre ensemble vers
un arc en ciel couleur eden dans le pays
de l'éveil
merci see
s'il ya un poète chaque jour
s'émerveillent devant chaque petit pas
de danse de bonheur de sa petite
merveille
alors peut-être que la poésie sauvera le
monde sur le chemin de l'amour des anges
au bout du songe quoi qu'il en soit pour
voyage vers notre avenir que l'on s'aime
et que l'on féconde à chacune de nos
secondes et alors il sera une fois où
plusieurs tous réunis sous le même toit
même toi même toi même toit car nous
avons le choix de rallumer la lueur de
l'espoir pour éclairer toutes nos
étoiles c'est lé dann dorado en voyage
en harmonie
[Musique]
merci
moi ma new york times hier à radio one
ce rendez vous où l âme humaine lamiaux
karim n'observons la mieux car amis au
matin conrad américaine de sitôt à la
mine soit de nouveau en action ofi tacle
l'omi lycéens il fait un iphone ou un
iphone faut à nouveau fallait mieux
quand il saura tout la minuad demi voix
il ne s'est fait à cherry la chine la
bad à vous ou à une alfa tabac de se
faire nominer feuilleton roumanie
initialement marianne
c'était quelques verbes suspendu dans le
temps on courir entre l'orient et
l'occident
car l'avenir appartiendra je l'espère à
ceux qui s'élèvent tolérant et pour
traduire en français
cette belle poésie suspendu dans le
temps qui s'en va vivre à l'étranger
prend l'ennemi pour ami qui ne jouit pas
de sa propre estime ne joua pas de celle
d'autrui
la nature d'un homme quelle qu'elle soit
est connue de tous
dutil s'imaginer pouvoir la cacher que
tom qui te plaisent tant qu'ils se
taisent et qui quand il parle perdent ou
gagnent en valeur le brave et pour
moitié langue pour moitié coeur quant au
reste ce n'est qu'apparence de sang et
de chair le vieillard qui déraisonne ne
se fera pas sage il est trop tard le
jeune homme qui déraisonne s'assagir à
nous demandons vous donnez nous
redemandons vous donner mais qui trop
souvent demande sera un jour privé privé
de la terre privée de la vie privée de
l'amour privée d'autrui
c'est un voyage en harmonie merci
je vous demande à plaisir s'il vous
plaît safouane mokaddem woods